[Music]
do you know the console contains the
collections of convenient functions for
you to perform common tasks quicker
in this episode we have sofia to share
with you some of these useful utilities
api
sofia
hi jason
hello everybody
before we dive right into it you should
know that the tricks i'm going to share
with you
only work inside the chrome devtools
console try to call them from your
scripts is sadly futile
however these tricks can boost your
console magic
first off the most useful shortcuts you
can type into the console
are the dollar sign shortcuts for
example dollar underscore returns the
value of the most recently evaluated
expression
let's evaluate two plus two the console
shows you the result right away
now to get to the previous value you
just need to type dollar underscore you
can refer to this value to compose a new
expression
for example add a number to the previous
value and get your result
moreover you can refer to the last five
dom elements you selected in the
elements panel
let's click on the hat element first
then on the body element
to refer to the most recent element type
dollar zero the console shows the body
element which is the most recent one to
refer to the previous element type
dollar one and get the hat element the
console remembers up to five elements
and you can refer to them in reverse
order by using numbers from zero to
four did you know that there's a short
alias for the query selector function
you can stop typing long commands like
document.queryselector
instead try the jquery way just type
dollar and the selector name as an
argument to achieve the same result
the selector function returns the first
element that matches the selector but
you can also specify a node to search
the elements from
there's a second optional parameter for
this
you can use shortcuts to specify a node
with this parameter let's select an
element in the dom tree so we can refer
to it
now type dollar then the selector as the
first argument and the shortcut to the
current element as the second argument
you'll get the first matching element
from the currently selected one
likewise there's a short alias for the
curie selectoral function it returns an
area of all the elements that match the
selector
the syntax is similar but instead of
just one dollar sign type 2. this
shortcut gets you all the svg elements
similarly you can specify the node to
search from this shortcut gets you the
svg elements that belong to the main
element
want to select elements by their x path
there's a shortcut for that too
just type dollar x and then as an
argument the xpath of the element for
example this shortcut returns all the p
elements on a page
not sure how to construct an x path
you can right click on any element copy
its x path and feed it to the shortcut
also
the console has a special query that
retrieves all objects created by a
constructor you specify
for example type query objects followed
by promise to discover all promise
objects that you have on your page
by the way there are some very useful
console login commands can you share
them with us jason
sure
besides console.log you can use dir and
table to lock arrays and objects to the
console
suppose we have this player object
defined we can use table to lock its
keys and values in the table form
much easier to view right
table is the shortcut for the
console.table function
similarly to clear the console we can
simply type the clear shortcut instead
of console.clear
there is another devtools tips video
about all the ways you can use the
console to lock things
make sure you check that out
alright
let's talk about how we can extract the
object keys and values and copy them in
one go
to get only the keys of an object
simply type keys and specify the object
name
here we can extract all the keys of our
player object
similarly you can get just the object
values by typing you guessed it values
followed by the object name
even better if you want to copy the
object values in one go
use the copy function to copy it to the
clipboard
now paste it wherever you want
next let's explore how you can monitor
stuff from the console
want to see all the event listeners
registered on a button
select the button in the elements panel
then type get event listeners and refer
to the selected button with the dollar
shortcut
aha
this button listens for the blur focus
and mouse events
need to monitor a specific event you can
let's monitor a window resize event
type monitor events then specify the
window object and the resize event
try resizing the window now
and voila you can see the list of
captured events in the console
when you're done stop all monitoring on
the window object with the unmonitor
events command
in addition to events you can also
monitor function calls
say you have this sum function on your
page
type monitor sum to log a message every
time this function gets called
let's trigger the sum call now
the console logs each function call
along with the arguments
don't forget to unmonitor the function
when you're done thanks sophia to learn
more about the console utilities apis go
to google.gov devtools console.utils
that's all see you for the next f2 tips
bye
[Music]